it's too late
[Music]
the absolutely stack list of anime in
Fall 2022 this year's winter starts off
with a bang as it continues the height
for older new anime releases with
beloved shows such as Vinland Saga bungo
stray dogs and Attack on Titan returning
for another season and unexpected yet
very welcome new shows like Nia automata
and Trigun Stampede has bound to be
loads of badass moments to keep viewers
on their toes so without further Ado
here are the most badass moments in
anime this winter of 2023
[Music]
we have the return of one of the most
badass issakai characters in Reese
memory Demon King Arness the goat
returns for a second season by killing a
God and Reviving him again what's more
is that all of this happened just in the
first episode of the series this moment
perfectly sets the tone for the
absurdity that's to come this season the
animation quality is more or less the
same but one thing to note is the change
in voice actors for anos
but I honestly think that the voice
doesn't deter me from the overall
feeling of seeing him kill the Heavenly
God in one hit and revive him again so
I'm excited for what's Yet to Come
especially after seeing just how much of
an Unstoppable force of nature he is
even the gods have to conjure up a plan
to have a chance at defeating him
[Music]
thank you
it's not every day that this anime goes
hard but when it does it mixes it really
well with an underlying emotional tone
that they've built up over the course of
a few episodes this one really pulls on
your heartstrings as we see our heroes
being cursed by aurobas with trauma we
see both iruma and Clara struggling with
their past and greatest fears and after
overcoming this iruma goes to save Clara
and we finally see his archery training
from bachico pay off ours coming in
clutch to save his friends from a
mind-controlled aurobas gives the main
Trio time to shine in their own way
no
[Music]
with a surprise appearance we have the
underrated Revenger
not to be confused with Tokyo Avengers
this anime is more akin to hell girl
with a group of Vigilantes taking
requests from dying people to take as
the name suggests Revenge this comes
from the first contract that the main
character gurima takes together with the
doctor murakami the team kill here is
visually fantastic because it shows the
devastation of the doctor's arrow shot
obliterating a boat in The Bodyguard
gurimat then comes in to finish the kill
using a gadget that allows him to
seemingly move fluidly and cross the
water beheading the target
alcohol
[Music]
we've got a fun ride ahead so why not
hand it to our sponsor for the day Tokyo
tree and sakurako these are two snack
boxes that allow you to experience the
wonders of Japan from your own home and
what better way to do it than through
these delicious treats that showcase
some of the best parts of Japanese Life
Spring as we know from anime is the
season of new beginnings it's also the
season of Sakura blooming and these two
snack boxes are here to let you get a
taste of that with their appropriately
themed treats Tokyo treat the monthly
pump snack box that gives you the most
exclusive seasonal snacks is here to
invite you to a Sakura picnic party I'm
sure looking forward to having you taste
these sweets because where else can you
find Sakura flavored Manju how about
this Peach flavored KitKat and some
Exquisite Ramen flavors that you just
won't find anywhere else however
sakurago's not ready to be left behind
this box which focuses more on the
authentic and local side of things both
the partnership with a lot of the best
local snack makers in Japan letting its
patrons experience authentic Artisan
Japanese snacks from the best of the
best oh and these come with kitchenware
too since we're on the topic of
traditional snacks though Sakura season
is also where sakurako shines and I'm
very very excited to get a taste of
these pink Mochi or the shortbread
cookies whether you prefer Tokyo treat
or sakurako I only have one thing to say
why not get both and let me tell you as
a friend that you shouldn't miss out on
the chance to experience the Sakura
season in a delicious way they're even
running a special promotion and you can
check it out through the link in the
description box thank you and back to
the show we go huh
laughs
with the same name as the one before we
now have Tokyo Revengers after the
episode 8 Cliffhanger when daiju beating
up our boy takimichi and hotgate Mikey
and draken finally come to the rescue
with a good old-fashioned Beatdown an
instant one of that actually the fake
out with daiju seemingly beating Mikey
and him bragging about it makes this all
the more satisfying to see him instantly
being on the ground after tasting one of
Mikey's kicks
you clearly don't know who you're
talking to so let me clue you in I am
not in danger Skyler
I am the danger
the badass moment also continues as hot
guy gets up from the beat down to warn
Mikey about the hundred black dragon
members waiting outside only to be
presented with the scene of drucken
beating all of them by himself the sight
of draken defeating a whole gang and
then just straight up waiting for Mikey
to finish will never not be badass
with one of the most well-received anime
this season we have Eminence in Shadow
atomic
back at it again with another issakai
but not just any other it's a guy it's
the edge Lord himself I found myself
picking this one scene in particular
because who doesn't like a guy who just
casually drops a second nuke in just
under 14 episodes and no one else would
be this crazy and off the rails except
for a sid garganu himself the scene the
Purple Haze the English and the literal
fact that he could have destroyed the
facility by just using a fraction of his
power but instead opted to entirely
obliterate it see that's what makes this
MC and this anime special because it
owns the cringe and doesn't shine away
from it and that act is entirely
encapsulated in how the MC deals with
his enemies in a glorious over the top
and sometimes unnecessary fashion but
hey that's why we enjoy the show isn't
it next up is Don Machi
[Music]
descending deeper into the dungeon Bell
and Ryu faced many challenges eventually
coming to a Breaking Point after
receiving fatal injuries in the dungeon
Ryu decided that the best course of
action is to sacrifice herself for Bell
even forcibly doing it as she lies and
wait for a coming demise considering it
as judgment or punishment Bell makes his
entrance and in typical Bell fashion he
enters the stage with a thunderous
Fireball with the music building up and
bells Argonaut on the ready he charges
forth without a single care we should
have seen this coming to be honest she
would have known how selfless he acts
when it comes to saving the people dear
to him the emotional weight behind the
scene is heavy for sure along with its
outstanding music and sound design
leaving the audience satisfied
[Music]
together
there's no way that this one couldn't be
on the list lady Nagant vs Deku with
villains on the loose and the trust in
Heroes reduced to nothing the whole
situation are pretty Grim for our
protagonist the whole thing then turned
from bad to worse when we found out that
the former hero lady Nagant is now after
Deku saying deku's transformation from a
crying mess into a competent and badass
hero was a really wild ride and that
change is effectively shown in his fight
against lady Nagant which proved to be
quite a challenge with her Quirk
focusing more on long range
Effectiveness combined with Airwalk
she's a foe even Deku would find hard
defeating but with deku's quick thinking
agility and spatial awareness alongside
his effective use of one for all he
manages to overcome yet another
formidable foe finishing it with a
Manchester smash
laughs
[Music]
boom go stray dogs gave us yet another
amazing moment with the introduction of
the hunting dogs with the armed
detective agency on the run after
falling for fyodor's Ploy the government
sent him one of its dangerous yet
effective units the hunting dogs their
introduction was badass enough on its
own but when we got the chance to
witness its members abilities it just
solidified how menacing and dangerous
these guys are for our main cast and
that was demonstrated when one man
single-handedly overpowered four members
of the Armed detective agency easily
destroying their means of escape and
cutting them down in an instant and
without chuya's interference the story
could have ended there with everyone's
backs in the corner the hunting dogs
will surely find their prey
next we have honest defeating the dragon
in the magical revolution of the
reincarnated Princess and The Genius
young lady Yuri fans Rejoice once again
as we finally have another Yuri isakai
after Bak Arena and it's a pretty good
one at that with a great story and
visuals this moment stands out as it
reminds me of the Excalibur scene from
Fate Stay Night setup for this scene is
amazing as there are clear Stakes with
the lives of the adventurers being in
danger if Arnis doesn't counter the
dragon's attack head on and counter she
did with an attack almost similar to the
Excalibur Noble Phantasm of saber from
the fake franchise the sword being a
symbol of arness's Relentless
determination to become a magician thus
making euphilia support her all the way
in the attack gives another layer to
their characters and their budding
romance to further even more
thank you
next up with probably the sanus entry is
Attack on Titan hanji's sacrifice
[Music]
so with the rumbling starting its
mindless Rampage the group found himself
right in its path due to flock damaging
their means of escape and the rumbling
slowly approaching just stop it stop it
well hey are you still alive why won't
you just just die I already just just
die hanji at that moment decided to do
what's necessary for the group to
survive charging fourth without fear nor
regret hanji took down one Colossal
Titan after another in an attempt to
slow them down utilizing her 3D
maneuvering gear to its fullest
potential but sadly it all comes to an
end when the heat became too much for
her to handle we then see hanji go out
in a blaze of glory fighting until the
very last moment with unwavering
determination without a single trace of
regret in her eyes it might be a sad
moment but she went out in a way that
was fitting for a member of the survey
corpse devote your hearts
thank you
this entry features one of the newest
animator air this season we have to be
in near automata with the adaptation
running smoothly and Faithfully to the
source material everyone's favorite
Android takes the center stage we first
introduced to the scene via a dogfight
sequence closely resembling the main
game which after that were then treated
to an iconic entrance from 2B herself
with its Stellar animation and fight
choreography the fluidity of how to be
fights is indeed mesmerizing flying from
one enemy to another and dispatching
each and every one of them with minimal
effect and of course we can't forget
about pod's assistance alongside its
excellent voice acting and soundtrack
and it's beautiful yet depressing story
and tone contrasted by the awesome and
chaotic fight scenes one can't simply
not admire this scene
thank you
and from one of the most loved anime
series we have the ultimate tag team of
Luffy and Yamato going up against kaido
in one piece though it has time and time
again surpassed our expectations in
regards to their animation always
managing to land a spot in most lists
for badass moments every season and here
they are yet again with the team up
attack from Yamato's white Serpent and
Luffy's jet cauldron against kaido
blowing our minds and us out of our
seats this winter of 2023 the scene of
Yamato preparing the attack with
momonosuke rising from the background
and Luffy riding him is a perfect setup
for what's about to come
with one of the most underrated yet
deserving anime to be on this list we
have tri-gun Stampede wolf wood using
the Punisher cross
[Music]
with the Remake looking really promising
one of the most iconic and beloved
characters in the OG series finally
makes his appearance in episode 4. after
being devoured whole by a massive sand
worm we bear witness to Wolf Wood's new
and upgraded Punisher cross now
outfitted with a powerful laser and its
classic machine with the remake of more
modded design has been implemented into
it
what makes this scene so badass is the
slow build up to it and the smooth and
satisfying way wolf wood uses this
hulking mass of a weapon which is only
made possible because of Studio Orange's
masterful way of making 3D animation
they've really outdone themselves with
this remake and that's why they deserve
to be on this list
[Music]
following that is boruto or more
specifically the fight between boruto
and gawagi in boruto episode 292 boruto
and gamaki finally face off and let's
just say it wasn't looking good for
kamaki as momoshiki boruto was
destroying him that's until he awakened
ishiki's power and an awesome turn of
events surprise garmaki
absorbs boruto's massive Rasengan and
counter-attacks the animation here
surprised most viewers seeing that
boruto didn't really have a good
reputation when it comes to animation
quality the hand-to-hand combat was a
breath of fresh air and has flashed back
after flashback ensues the fight gives
the viewer that emotional kick that
we've been looking for with garbaki's
explosive final hit something that truly
made viewers have a second thought
boruto becomes Ace in what could be one
of the most badass moments in Winter
2023 fukabaki
[Music]
thank you
I'm sorry Mike
this
this whole thing could have been avoided
let me die empty
and those aren't my badass moments from
the 2023 winter season of anime so far
with a number of memorable moments we've
already seen just at the start of this
year we can almost certainly look
forward to even more so in the future
months let me know what you think in the
comment section below I'm glad to have
you here and thank you so much again for
watching this video
[Music]